good morning to noble forum and the
press conference for the announcement of
this year's Nobel Prize in Physiology or
medicine so what I will do is to first
read the announcement in Swedish and
then in English and then we will proceed
to some scientific background
information and then we will open up for
questions
noble fisherman Eva Karolinska
Institutet or a dog
Whistler that of noble preset physiology
error medicine over tortoise and Sexton
scale till the others Yoshinori assuming
for an objector of mechanism or for out
of agility the Nobel assembly at
Karolinska Institute has today decided
to award the 2016 Nobel Prize in
Physiology or medicine to Yoshinori who
sue me for his discoveries or mechanisms
for a topology so with that I would like
to leave the world to professor Maria
Masucci who will describe a little bit
about the science behind this price so
please Maria
okay Yoshinori Osumi was born in Fukuoka
Japan in 1945 he started the seminal
work for which he is awarded a nobel
prize at york university and is
currently an emeritus professor at the
Tokyo Institute of Technology in
Yokohama this year's Nobel Prize in
Physiology or medicine is awarded for
discoveries concerning out of regime the
word out of aji is derived from the
Greek language and means self eating to
eat oneself in the mythology of many
ancient human cultures the self eating
dragon is a symbol of self-reliance and
renewal in the human body self eating
out of a gene is a process by which our
selves reduce their own components to
release energy and to build new
functional parts al-tofah G was first
observed in the 1960s soon after the
discovery of the lysosome an organelle
that contains the enzymes used by the
cells to disassemble proteins sugars and
lipids into their reusable building
blocks in addition to the lysosome
scientists observed another quite
different type of organelle composed of
a double membrane surrounding some
cytoplasmic material they also observed
that vesicles appears in the cytoplasm
of cells under stress such as during
starvation the vesicles
extended into double membrane that
progressively engulfed a portion of the
cytoplasm forming what became known as
an alto phagosome the outer phagosome
later fused with allowances on where the
content was broken down by lysosomal
enzymes during the next 30 years little
more became known about out of a gym the
mechanism for the process and the
significance of autophagy for Physiology
or disease remained a mystery the
situation started to change in the 1990s
where your she Noriyasu me decided the
plot to study the process of autophagy
in baker's yeast yeast cells contain a
single large lysosome known as the
vacuole Osumi found a clever way to
visualize the accumulation of
out-of-focus ohm's in the vacuole by
making star cells unable to degrade the
content of the van corn he then used
this method to search among thousands of
mutants for East cells that had lost the
capacity to activate out of Ag this
ingenious strategy led to the discovery
that our tofu G is regulated by a large
number of genes as many as 15 essential
out of Ag genes were identified in the
first study published in 1993 having
discovered the al-tofah G genes also we
moved on to the next question that was
to understand how the products of the
genes work together
thanks to this pioneering work we have
today a detail understanding of the
molecular mechanism of ecology
Osumi showed
that stress signals initiate a cascade
of events that through the formation of
different protein complex control each
steps in the formation of the outer
phagosome from the initial fusion of
vesicles to the extension and bending of
the membranes at the sequester the cargo
and finally to the fusion of the outer
phagosome with a lysosome
Osumi and his colleagues were also the
first to identify genes that control
octopod in mammalian cells
this allowed the production of research
tools that have transformed Delta G into
one of the most intensely studied topics
of biomedical research thanks to the
work of Yoshinori of Sumi and many
others that followed in his footsteps we
now know that our Tofurky regulates
important physiological function of the
cells and that the effects of ecology
are associated with many human diseases
for example otology is required for cell
differentiation that keep rise to the
many different type of cells that
constitute our body by recycling part of
the cellular content
Altaf EG allows our body to cope with
starvation and with other types of
stress by capturing invading viruses and
bacterias otology is essential for the
body defense against infection through
the removal of damaged proteins and
organelles autophagy promotes cell
renewal failure of ethology is therefore
associated with cell aging and with many
diseases of old age sanchez Alzheimer's
disease and type 2 diabetes finally too
much of tofurkey might have undesired
effects in counts as for example in
cancer we're out of AG can promote the
growth of tumor cells and the resistance
to ants the cancer drugs
the discoveries made I by your scenario
Suman have been instrumental in
revealing the mechanism and significance
of a fundamental physiological process
and there is growing hope that this
knowledge will lead the development of
new strategies for the treatment of many
human diseases thank you very much
so before opening up for questions I
would just like to introduce in addition
to Maria Masucci professor Niels you're
on Larsen and on a professor an avid L
who's also the chair of the Nobel
Committee and they or here assisting to
answer questions so that I open up for
questions about this year's Nobel Prize
so yes I did I was in touch with
professors who me this morning right
after the decision was made he seemed
surprised the first thing is that was ah
I think he was actually not maybe
expecting this and and he was surprised
but very pleased and asked if he was
allowed to leave the building and of
course I explained that he would expect
a lot of phone calls and I think he was
very very pleased so it was very nice to
talk to him it is eight million Swedish
kronor
and the more question here we have a
question this is the journalist from
people's daily online we are very happy
that this year there is another Asian
Nobel laureates because last year was
the Chinese - yo-yo also got the Nobel
laureates so my question is what's your
comment on the research improvements in
Asia in the Madison area yes I think of
course the Nobel prizes in international
prize and takes no consideration to
where and one is from and I think it is
apparent to anyone in science that Asian
science is is growing enormously not
least of course in China so I think
maybe we're seeing the beginning of this
we should remember that the price we're
awarding today were for discoveries that
were done in the 90s so I think we can
expect much more to come so it's going
to be an Asian Nobel laureates next time
also not not even we know about that
thank you
yes my name is Anna coast mom from the
Swedish radio company
what about is it Parkinson or cancer or
where do you think it is the most
important contribution for the medicine
I think they are left
Anna Vidal answer that question okay so
this is a prize for basic discoveries
but it's already clear that autologous
critically involved both in the origin
of disease and in our way of handling
counteracting diseases and this applies
to a broad range of diseases such as
cancer neurodegenerative Alzheimer as
Maria said inflammatory diseases
diabetes but exactly how this works and
the different risk their disease areas
that is what has been possible to study
so me has enabled totally new research
areas that are now very active in
addressing these questions neural
degeneration definitely is an active
area as is cancer but the price is for
the basic knowledge the mechanisms and
tools allowing these further research
now night lines that are now exploding
so we can only hope for a broad impact
in various diseases okay thank you more
questions here is one question
in terms of applications are there any
concrete trials going on with drugs that
are interfering with this system there
are lots and lots of activities of
attempts to both stimulate and
counteract at ofuji and that it's a very
complex biology but there's a lot of
activities and the specific ways of
really really tailoring treatment is
we're not really there yet but it's it's
really ongoing many many clinical trials
but no drugs on the market yet but there
are drugs that affect a tough OG and
also drugs where we didn't really know
the mechanism and still don't but it's
that they somehow affect us - Tata Fuji
but how this specific specifically work
we don't really have those drugs yet
maybe one can mention that most of the
trials ongoing right now or for cancer
did we see any one more who wanted to
ask anything I know there are many eager
for interviews that are welcome
afterwards so I think we can then
probably conclude this press conference
thanks so much for coming to noble forum
today thank you